[Música]
quando você acorda pela manhã
qual a primeira coisa que você faça
escova os dentes assistir levanta da
cama
se você for como eu e 46% das pessoas
que possuem um smartphone
você checa as atualizações do ats ap e
das redes sociais
antes mesmo de sair da cama e ali já
ross primeiras intervenções nosso dia
esse é o nosso mundo hoje é assim que a
gente vive na área digital
vivemos uma vida online onde lhe o time
definir momentos da vida real
conectados ancoradas em plataformas
tecnológicas e aí vale a gente pensar
sobre esse conceito de vida real para
muitos ainda tido como apenas a vida
offline
mas nesse novo contexto a vida online
também passa a ser real
só que a apresentada e conectada em uma
nova versão do smartphone é como uma
memória externa da nossa vida como um hd
externo uma memória expandida com
capacidade infinita
a gente não precisa mais lembrar do nome
daquela vinícola que realizou durante a
última viagem para o chile a gente
acessa o tripadvisor e ver os lugares
visitados
nós não precisamos guardar quem foi o
primeiro imperador do império romano a
gente acessa o wikipédia e sabe
facilmente que foi augusto quem fundou
esse grande império o celular
ele é praticamente uma prótese dos
nossos corpos se a gente sai de casa
esquece a carteira está tudo certo
a gente pede dinheiro emprestado se vira
durante o dia
agora se a gente esquece o celular com
certeza a gente volta correndo para casa
para buscar esse aparelho ele faz parte
do nosso dia a dia e isso me faz lembrar
que nós seres humanos com 25 anos ou
mais
somos a última geração até
vivido a era analógica os mais jovens
não fazem idéia do que é viver em uma
sociedade sem conexão não sabem o que é
consultar o telefone de uma loja nas
páginas amarelas da lista telefônica do
que quer viajar com o mapa de papel na
mão ou ter que se limitar à grade de
programação das emissoras de tv nos
limitavam ao conteúdo que eles achavam
que era relevante que a gente assiste se
hoje a gente tem liberdade de escolha
para consumir conteúdo relevante para os
nossos interesses para produzir conteúdo
criativo e compartilhar isso com o mundo
ea cada interação
nessa realidade virtual nós vamos
deixando rastros de quem somos nós vamos
construindo uma digital espontâneo de
quem a gente é o mapa formado por dados
nós falamos abertamente do que gostamos
do que odiamos com quem conversamos por
onde andamos ea cada laico em uma página
a cada foto compartilhada a cada vídeo
assistido a gente coloca um pontinho
nesse mapa digital infinito a respeito
de quem nós somos
agora faça uma reflexão quantas vezes
por dia você interage com uma máquina
1030 100 vezes
imagine então o volume de dados que você
está gerando diariamente multiplica isso
pela quantidade de pessoas nesse salão
pela quantidade de pessoas que vivem
nessa cidade pela população brasileira
pela população mundial
você acha isso muito pois um relatório
recentemente divulgado pela cisco
gigante americana de tecnologia em redes
prevê que em 2021
nós teremos três vezes mais dispositivos
conectados à internet
do que a população mundial até lá a
velocidade da banda larga irá tudo brar
em relação ao que a gente tem hoje
isso significa que a gente vai ter ainda
muito mais dados transitando na internet
eles prevêem também que que em 2021
nós amaríamos 5 milhões de anos para
poder assistir a todos os vídeos que
irão circular na rede a cada mês ea
gente está falando de 2021 praticamente
daqui a três anos
isso é brincadeira esse imenso volume de
dados sendo gerado em diferentes
formatos em altíssima velocidade
esses registros de sentimentos opiniões
e comportamentos
imaginem agora o que dá pra fazer com
essa informação o valor que isso tem
para as corporações
dizem que beira é um novo petróleo mas a
verdade é muito mais que isso
o petróleo é um recurso mineral finito
dados não dados são gerados
infinitamente enquanto houver vida na
terra haverá a geração de dados e com
isso a gente já percebe o quanto que
dados trazem poder
na verdade a informação extraída desses
dados é que traz poder dados assim como
petróleo precisam ser refinadas a gente
conseguir a informação relevante e útil
aplicável nós cientistas de dados
nós limpamos filtramos estruturamos
cruzamos e modelamos esses dados em
busca de padrões relevantes
nós realmente torturamos os dados até
que eles confessem e surge então com os
sites criativos e de inovação surge
novos produtos novos serviços novos
sistemas
nasce um mundo que atende desejos que
nós mesmos não sabemos que temos desejos
cultos nas nossas interações sociais e
quando a gente fala de dados
muitas pessoas ainda pensam inúmeros
objetivos e frios mas a verdade é que
quando a gente fala de dados
nós estamos falando fundamentalmente de
pessoas
são registros das suas alegrias e de
suas dores complexidades e das suas
simplicidades a olhar para esses dados
que formam essa selva digital gigantesca
e cada vez mais em expansão e ainda
muito pouco explorada
nós estamos olhando pra humanidade olhar
pra dados
a gente olha para culturas sociedade a
gente olha pra etna grafia digital ea
então surge a necessidade da gente
significa sem informação dados por si só
não tem sentido quem dá sentido a eles
somos nós seres humanos que analisamos e
interpretamos essa informação ea então é
necessário praticar empatia se conectar
as histórias e narrativas humanas que
estão por trás desses registros se
colocar no lugar do outro é um dos
grandes poderes do big idea e ao
entender a força que reside nessas
grandes base de dados
a gente pode escolher o que fazer com
essa informação
a gente pode optar fazer uso disso
apenas pra atender objetivos privados
como o aumento de vendas aumento de
lucros empresariais
a gente também pode usar esses dados
para fazer o bem
nasce então iniciativas de impacto
social positivo que pretendem
revolucionar o mundo a partir da análise
e significação de dados
isso é deitar fogo
ou dados para o bem dados públicos dados
transacionais estados de conversas
sociais
tudo isso pode ser matéria prima na
construção de pontes entre problemas
sociais e soluções reais
a partir disso surgem coletivos de
cientistas de dados que se reúnem de
forma independente para solucionar algum
problema impactante na sua comunidade ou
ainda grandes organizações que conectam
os cientistas de dados ao redor do mundo
elevam para trabalhar problemas
relevantes ao redor do planeta
uma dessas organizações é a de que a
carne
sediada em nova york eles conectam e
plugam cientistas de dados a diferentes
problemas diferentes situações de pacto
ao redor do mundo e então eles vão
construindo juntos histórias incríveis
de protagonismo e mudança social
totalmente guiados por dados mentes e
corações
entre os projetos já desenvolvidos por
esse grupo tem um deles que trata de
construir ruas com o tráfego com um
trânsito mais seguro em quatro grandes
metrópoles norte-americanas
para isso cientistas de dados cruzaram
modelos preditivos de tráfego a
identificação de padrões em acidentes
envolvendo ciclistas e pedestres
um outro projeto muito legal envolve a
construção de um algoritmo para tornar
mais inclusivo e melhor distribuída a
concessão de microcrédito para pequenos
empreendedores no senegal no brasil uma
iniciativa que vem ganhando cada vez
mais destaque a operação serenata de
amor aprendizagem de máquina para
auditar contas públicas e combater a
corrupção existe disponível na rede para
todos nós uma base de dados onde são
armazenadas todas as solicitações de
reembolso apresentadas pelos deputados
federais
são notas fiscais referentes a
transporte hospedagem
alimentação que eles realizam durante as
viagens
só que ninguém olha para seus mais de
dados em detalhe nem mesmo a câmera e aí
que entra a operação serenata de amor
eles um grupo de cientistas de dados
treinou uma robô chamada rose pra
avaliar todas essas notas baseadas nas
regras que a própria câmara define para
reembolso
e então eles colocam um robô para rodar
ea cada suspeita de gasto indevido ela
envia um e-mail para o deputado
questionando aquele valor e ainda mantém
um canal aberto de conversa com a
população via twitter o uso de dados
abertos e aprendizagem de máquina
totalmente voltado para o bem social
eu também faço parte de um coletivo
científico de dados
o nosso trabalho deu origem à matrioska
um estudo contínuo que busca significará
as vozes que ecoam na internet sobre
feminismo empoderamento feminino nós
podemos nós buscamos entender o que as
pessoas falem como se relacionam com
esse movimento de mulheres que buscam a
igualdade de gênero na sociedade
nós ouvimos de forma aberta e neutra
essas conversas sem questionamentos sem
induções sem diferenciação de gênero
etnia origem
não importa se são conversas positivas
ou negativas
o nosso papel não é julgar é
simplesmente compreender e evidenciar em
2016 nós realizamos um estudo com 800
mil conversas coletadas na internet
então observamos que 63% das pessoas que
falam sobre feminismo empoderamento
feminino na internet
se é apresentam como mulheres
observamos também que 89% das conversas
vêm de usuários comuns frente apenas 4%
de influenciadores digitais e 3% de
organizações
a gente percebeu também que 95% das
conversas sobre o movimento é o que a
gente pretende o que a gente chama
ativismo de sofá ou seja o ativismo que
nasce diretamente nas redes sociais na
internet sem ligação direta com
movimentos de rua quando a gente tenta
compreender que sentimentos estão
atrelados a esse movimento a maioria
deles se relaciona com ironia e sarcasmo
e além disso se fala muito em orgulho
empatia e indignação e ao buscar o
significado desse movimento para as
pessoas que falam dele nas redes 23% das
pessoas relacionam empoderamento e
feminismo a busca de igualdade enquanto
que 20% fala que relaciona isso há
conhecimento informação apenas uma
pequena parcela fala de justiça e luta
essas leituras trazem luz sobre as
formas como a sociedade se relaciona com
um tema tão relevante atual nos mostra a
importância das redes ao na escola claro
em contato com assuntos que antes não
faziam parte do nosso dia a dia são as
leituras analíticas e racionais
mostrando evoluções culturais e assim
como a produção de dados é infinita
as potencialidades de uso dos dados
também cabe a nós compreendermos os seus
nuances e sabermos como direcionar para
ações impactantes para gerar o bem maior
e esse é o grande movimento do nosso
tempo a olhar para o próximo nos
reconhecermos como humanidade conectados
e uma única rede energética e quanto
mais pessoas estiverem cientes do
potencial analítico da nossa era de como
que a gente pode hackear a sociedade a
partir do nosso próprio comportamento
mais protagonista de mudanças virão
e dados entram como tijolos digitais na
construção dessas novas pontes
são mudanças profundas essas que a gente
vive como sociedade são novas formas de
interagir de olhar para fora e também de
olhar para dentro
vamos fazer uma reflexão
pense em tudo que nós já construímos
nesse planeta como humanidade em todas
as civilizações que já passaram por aqui
em todas as revoluções intelectuais nos
inventos que mudaram o curso da história
nós fizemos isso de forma independente
isolados em pequenos grupos ou
movimentos
imaginem agora o potencial evolutivo que
temos
ao estarmos conectados somos hoje
bilhões de seres humanos
habitando esse planeta nós somos bilhões
de cérebros pensantes interagindo em
rede compartilhando idéias deixando
registros map haveis de quem nós somos
imaginem o privilégio que temos da gente
estar vivo nesse momento da história
experience ando todas essas
transformações co criando essa mudança
de era
nós vivemos um momento de avanço
exponencial do conhecimento onde a gente
está deixando o segmento horizontal
dessa curva e fazendo manobra para o
segmento vertical qual que é o limite
disso não tem o que a gente precisa é
que mais e mais pessoas tenham uma
compreensão que isso tudo que a gente
está vivendo
pra quê mais mente se sintam instigados
a usar essas gigantescas massas de dados
em
a exigência analítica para revolucionar
o mundo para gerar impacto positivo para
fazer o bem picado
[Aplausos]